welcome to the man of recaps this is
ozark seasons one through three leading
up to the fourth and final season meet
marty bird a mild-mannered financial
advisor in chicago but marty has a
secret for years now he's been
laundering money for a mexican drug
cartel tonight they're summoned by their
contacts dell because marty's partner
bruce has been skimming money for
himself which is a big no-no now marty
legitimately didn't know but the
cartel's gonna kill him anyway so he
starts spewing whatever nonsense he can
to try to save his life he randomly had
a brochure for the lake of the ozarks in
his pocket so he starts rambling this is
a money laundering paradise let me keep
working for you i'll do way more than i
was doing here bill knows marty's
scrambling but he's curious he's like
okay you bought yourself three months to
launder eight million dollars if you
fail we'll kill you then so marty
uproots his family and they all move
down to beautiful missouri now the birds
had a pretty normal family life marty's
wife wendy knew about the laundry but
they were never supposed to be in any
real danger actually their marriage was
in a rough spot right now because marty
just found out she was having an affair
but the cartel does not like
complications so marty and wendy have
more pressing issues now the kids are
too smart to buy their parents weird
excuses for this move so almost
immediately when he gives up your
father's laundry money for a mexican
drug cartel and they might kill us all
so the birds buy their new lake house
which comes with its former owner old
man buddy who's dying soon anyway his
naked morning swims just add to the
rustic charm now what is money
laundering basically you take your cash
from illegal drug dealing mix it in with
a legitimate business you can't tell
what's what the government can't seize
it so marty needs a business to launder
through and the winner is the blue cat
lodge its current owner is rachel and
business isn't great but marty's like
hey let me invest i'll turn it around
and she's like hey man sure good luck
but there was a huge problem back on day
one when the cartel cash was stolen out
of marty's motel room marty quickly
finds the culprits a local family of
lowlifes the langmores now the langmores
aren't exactly criminal masterminds
except ruth who's real street smart and
extremely foul-mouthed they give the
money back for now but ruth's gonna play
the long game have marty teach her how
to launder money then kill him and take
it she convinces marty to take her on as
an assistant and becomes his curly hair
to jesse pinkman so it's all going well
at the blue cat but not nearly well
enough to meet the cartel's deadline and
marty realizes he's gonna have to play
dirty there's a strip club in town and
it becomes apparent the owner's already
using it to launder money of his own so
marty gives ruth her first task break in
and steal the safe and ruth's got that
no problem she gives some cash to
underage kids then calls the cops while
the owner's gone they get the safe easy
peasy but marty's not looking for cash
he takes the title to the guy's fake
shell corporation and because it's all
illegal he can't do anything marty's the
proud new owner of a strip club that's
not marty scene though so he puts ruth
in charge as manager a job she's
incredibly good at but now marty has
messed with the business of the local
crime lords the snells who have got
secret poppy fields out on their farm
that's heroin jacob snell is a pretty
nice guy who if you ask him how it's
going he'll launch into a 20-minute
story about how the power company
flooded his family off this land 200
years ago but it's his wife darlene who
you really want to watch out for she's a
full psychopath who will kill you as
soon as look at you now the snells
self-identify as hillbillies and i
couldn't tell you the difference between
these two words but they really don't
like being called rednecks more on that
later so jacob snell introduces himself
to marty and tries to intimidate him but
marty's like sorry i work for the
mexican cartel nice to meet you though
marty still needs more ways to launder
money and construction is always a good
option there's a local pastor who
preaches out on the water and it's like
hey why don't we build you a church but
marty didn't know that's how the snells
distribute their heroin out on the water
where there's no cop interference so the
snows have a less friendly meeting with
marty where it's like hey maybe we can't
touch you but if you don't get that
preacher back on the water we're gonna
cut that baby out of his nice pregnant
wife meanwhile the fbi's in town and
they can't prove it but they know
exactly what marty's up to so coming in
undercover is agent petty his target is
rustling more ruth's uncle they become
fishing buddies and petty puts it out
there that he's gay now at first russ is
very homophobic because turns out he's
gay too now as marty trusts ruth with
more responsibility she starts to really
like her boss but there's someone she
wants to impress even more her father
caidling or who's in prison and a real
bad dad so she's going through with her
plan to kill marty by electrifying his
dock make it look like an accident but
oh luckily it doesn't work agent petty
heard about the plan from ross and
dewired it wendy the season starts
working for a realtor who's a real
mama's boy but one day she's sassing him
a little too hard who walks into the
street and hit by a garbage truck and
when when he sees how inflated funeral
costs are she buys a funeral home to
help with the money laundering so marty
and wendy working together which can
strain a marriage in the best of
circumstances sometimes things are good
as the threat of imminent death brings
them closer together but other times
things are bad as they get into some
truly epic shouting matches they average
out at a baseline of let's just try to
survive now in the great tradition of
breaking bad it's time for family
breakfast where we check in on the kids
their teenage daughter charlotte is
generally not taking the situation very
well but their younger son jonah takes
it almost too well he reads all about
money laundering and wants to help the
family business jonah becomes good
friends with old man buddy who teaches
him how to shoot guns charlotte goes
down to party cove and hooks up with a
frat boy even though she's only 16 but
the next day he leaves town without
saying goodbye it's like yeah the
tourists always leave so charlotte
befriends a local wyatt langmore ruth's
cousin who's actually really smart loves
books his younger brother whose name is
three not so much now as marty hits his
three-month deadline he's actually
pulled it off laundered more money than
anyone thought possible as a reward the
cartel gives him even more cash to
launder so this is his life for the
foreseeable future now marty's become
close with rachel at the blue cat and
dare i say they're a little flirty but
when she finally checks the books and
sees what marty's up to she's pretty mad
but marty's like we can't stop or the
cartel will kill us all when she
realizes he's not exaggerating she finds
the hidden cash in the wall grabs a big
sack and pieces out of there then russ
langmore has really fallen for agent
petty they make plans to open a fishing
shop together and it seems agent penny's
kind of fallen for us too which makes it
all the more awkward when he reveals
he's a narc he wants to use russ to get
to ruth to get to marty but ruth's too
smart for that figures out he's wearing
a wire russ doesn't see a way out of
this so he thinks the best plan is to
kill marty bird now take his cash and
run but ruth figures out what he's up to
so when they get to the blue cat oh she
electrified the dock ruth murders her
uncles to save her mentor marty she
really loves her cousin wyatt and now
she's got a lie about killing his dad
agent petty also does not take the news
very well there's yet another problem
when the pastor resumes construction on
the church the only way marty can make
him stop is by telling him what the
snails are up to he won't stand for this
he stops preaching and jacob smells like
marty this was your fault cause they did
exactly what they said they were gonna
do he finds his baby delivered but his
wife gone with all the craziness here
marty's like hey wendy take the kids and
run but running unexpectedly is against
the cartel rules luckily old man buddies
here to cover their escape but when that
guy doesn't check in dell comes to town
for some good old-fashioned toenail
removal marty doesn't break though so
they'll trust him so they have a sit
down with the snells marty's got a plan
how they can all work together if the
snails flood some of their land they'll
connect to the river and then they can
build a riverboat casino casinos are the
best way to launder a ton of money and
in exchange the cartel will handle
distribution on the snell's heroine now
this is a great deal for all parties so
everything's gonna work out but dell
also not knowing how it's different from
a hillbilly calls them rednecks and oh
darlene does not take kindly to that so
marty calls his wife hey things are not
going to quiet down here you guys should
run for good but the kids don't want to
leave their dad behind they're like hey
if we're all in danger at least we'll be
in it together so they decide to come
home and stick it out in the ozarks and
that's where season one comes to an end
so in season two to replace dell the
cartel sends their american lawyer helen
pierce who is a real boss they try
to cover up dell's death but helen's
like don't mess with me we know the
snell's killed him and the only way to
make it right they killed one of the
cartel's top guys so now they gotta kill
one of their own darlene loved that guy
like a son though she does not approve
and so with that little snafu out of the
way things settle down to a nice new
normal the birds are out of immediate
danger now they just have to open a
casino and it's wendy bird who takes
point on the legal side she used to work
in politics knows how the game's played
big player in the ozarks is charles
wilkes who takes a liking to wendy and
is happy to help out and wendy's willing
to play dirty blackmailing senators to
get the casino approved but charlie's
not helping just for friendship he wants
to build a whole entertainment district
around the casino unfortunately the
snells owned the land and they're barely
willing to build a casino they'll never
go for it so wilks is like forget it
time out but wendy tricks him into
accepting cartel money for his charity
so now he's implicated she blew up their
friendship but is getting the casino but
there's illegal obstacles too you can't
open a casino without approval from the
kansas city mob luckily marty knows
someone with casey mob connections it's
old man buddy yes he's friends with the
leader frank cosgrove from their days
back in detroit and so with buddy
vouching for marty frank's in the mob
just needs their cut now marty continues
to trust ruth with more and more
responsibilities because she's very
effective at getting things done she
delegates her strip club duties to
mama's boy realtor guy who is not well
suited for the job falls in love with
the first stripper he sees but now with
her uncle's dead her bad dad cade
langmore is paroled from prison to be
the guardian for her cousins with wants
her dad to be impressed with how well
she's doing working for marty but he's
not impressed he robs a diner for no
reason and is just really a bad guy
meanwhile rachel from the blue cat is on
a drug bender soon ends up in prison and
right there to catch her is special
agent petty he has her wear a wire
against marty and though he doesn't get
much he gets enough to get a warrant to
search his house marty's too smart to
hide stuff in his house though they're
gonna find nothing but he doesn't need
to actually find anything the fed's just
talking to you will make the cartel
suspicious marty vouchers for ruth even
though he actually just learned she
tried to kill him earlier but the
cartels got to test her themselves they
put her through the company onboarding
seminar and ruth's a tough cookie she
doesn't show it but she's a little
traumatized but now the problem is the
snell's poppy field helen's like hey you
have to burn it before the feds find it
but that's millions of dollars they'd
rather take their chances so old man
buddy who at this point is part of the
family volunteers to go on down there
and burn it himself it's the most fun
he's had in years unfortunately though
just then his heart finally gives out
and he dies and so agent petty's whole
investigation has come up empty but that
night talking to rachel marty almost
implicates himself and she kisses him to
shut him up she reveals she's wearing a
wire agent petty's pretty erratic she
does not trust him so she and marty have
one quick real kiss and she leaves her
good this time now the nice boat
preachers become a crazy homeless
preacher living on the street with his
baby so pretty soon child services takes
his kid away but then he kidnaps wendy
he blames her marty pulls some crazy
strings to get his baby back but he
still doesn't trust him he's too far
gone he's gonna kill wendy now so marty
shoots this guy bleeds out in front of
him marty is extremely scarred by this
it's his wife wendy who's gotta help him
through it and pick up the slack running
the business so now the birds have a new
baby zeke and it's time for family
breakfast to check in on the kids this
season jonah opens his own offshore
account and starts laundering some funds
while charlotte loses all respect for
her parents authority in fact she tries
to become an emancipated minor but
ultimately doesn't meanwhile darlene
snell still does not approve of working
with the mexicans he's a little worried
his wife's gonna try to kill him and he
was right she poisoned his coffee it's a
strange kind of touching farewell as
she's like honey i love you but i had to
do this and he's like oh darlene i love
you too i ain't even mad so now
darlene's gonna stop the casino deal but
she has one request that would make her
reconsider all season she's wanted to
adopt a baby and now she specifically
wants baby zeke wendy's like yo you
killed his mother absolutely not but
ultimately they have no other choice so
they give baby zeke to darlene meanwhile
ruth still desperately craves her bad
dad's approval she agrees to help him
steal marty's cash but he doesn't keep
it in the funeral home like she thought
turns out mary's found a fantastic new
hiding spot inside buddy's mausoleum
after this ruth realizes her dad is
awful and decides to cut ties with him
for good so kate goes to agent petty
hoping to take down marty but it's like
hey you don't even know marty what are
you doing here and kade's got a temper
oh he attacks him kills this guy bye
agent petty so kate goes back to ruth
like hey i'm gonna skip town give me all
the cash you got or i'm gonna tell wyatt
you killed his father yes wyatt's been
real depressed about his father's death
they have imaginary jam sessions and
he's been investigating it but now ruth
has to come clean i'm so sorry but i
killed your dad and wyatt does not take
it well so cage is real desperate now he
goes after charlotte bird for some
reason and this crosses a line wendy
pays him to get out of town so now after
all the crazy obstacles the birds are
finally opening their casino but marty
has made plans to skip town he's like
wendy we're never gonna be safe here we
gotta run but wendy's been talking to
helen who's like hey you guys are out of
the doghouse now the cartel's really
impressed with what you've done here
you've got a bright future with us
wendy's like yo marty i'm not running
we're not gonna be safer by leaving the
cartel we're gonna be safer by getting
further in and turns out wendy didn't
actually pay cade to leave town she had
the cartel assassinate him oh wendy
birds did you just put out a hit on a
guy she comes clean to ruth and it's
complicated but ruth understands but
when marty finds out he's now a little
bit terrified of who his wife's becoming
and that's where season two comes to an
end with the bird family sticking it out
in the ozarks so in season three the
birds are the proud new owners of a
riverboat casino ruth langmore is his
right-hand woman been promoted to casino
manager part of her job is coordinating
cash drops with the kansas city mob
who's in charge of transportation but
her co-worker there is frank cosgrove's
son frank jr who's just a real d-bag he
goes too far threatening her one night
and ruth's not taking that she kicks him
in the nuts and throws him right off the
boat this is very much against mob rules
though frank jr is supposed to be
untouchable so to smooth things over
marty's got to give them an even bigger
cut but as part of it he marks ruth as
untouchable too so besides that little
snafu things have settled into a nice
new normal but down in mexico marty's
employer is now at war with a rival
cartel now wendy bird sees an
opportunity here she has the idea to
expand into legitimate businesses as a
safety net in case their boss is killed
he'll be able to pass it down to his
kids legally marty hates this idea he
doesn't want to get deeper in he still
wants to get out and in fact the birds
fight more than ever this season they
start going to couples therapy where
they talk out their problems in very
vague terms but it's not really working
because marty is bribing the therapist
to take his side but wendy thinks her
idea is a good one and takes it to alan
who takes it to their boss who wants a
personal meeting with wendy and so she
gets to meet omar navarro the cartel
leader like many powerful people he's
mostly soft-spoken when he gives him her
elevator pitch and he's just like good
make it happen so now the plan is to buy
a second riverboat casino one that's
failing because a better one open across
the street but marty wants the deal to
fall through he's working against wendy
in fact he goes to his new friends at
the kansas city mob and has them
sabotage the fireworks display on the
new casino blowing it up so now the
owners don't want to sell but ruth's
been investigating anti-cheating
technology and they decide to use it on
offense get jackpots on all their slot
machines wendy's gotten really good at
playing dirty so the deal goes through
but that attracts the attention of the
fbi again expanding to another casino so
quickly has given them cause for an
audit making it nearly impossible to
launder the lead investigator this time
is agent maya miller who's real friendly
type but really good at her job one way
marty tries to keep laundering is with
mom's boy realtor this season he
proposes to strip a girlfriend with a
diamond made out of his dead mom okay he
actually inherited a lot of money from
his mother and now the birds have him
lose it at their casino and they'll pay
him back which wendy assures him is not
illegal turns out it is illegal though
and by the end of the season agent
miller catches him so with marty now
secretly working against his wife he
bugs her phone and turns out she's been
having late-night convos with their boss
navarro he just calls to talk about his
feelings because he kind of likes her
but being a drug lord he soon discovers
someone's listening in and soon
discovers it's marty so he abducts marty
down to mexico to meet him in person
where he's given a room with a view and
authentic mexican food it's also a test
to see if the ozark crew can keep
laundering without marty and ruth has
learned a lot but long story short not
enough turns out marty is something
special he's really good at manipulating
financial systems and so marty having
survived what he thought was definitely
the end makes up with his wife they're a
team again for now now there's a new
member of the family this season when
wendy's younger brother ben comes to
stay with him uncle ben's an awesome
free spirited dude who quickly settles
into buddy's old role but he is severely
bipolar and went off his meds is pretty
erratic and so it's time for family
breakfast let's check in on the kids
charlotte has matured a lot this season
she's down to help the family now starts
working for her mom on the legal side of
things jonah gets a drone and uses it to
peep on helen pierce's daughter who's
staying with her mom for the summer
there's a whole thing where she has a
crush on this bad boy but by the end
it's jonah she picks yeah he has his
first kiss now wyatt langmore got into
college last season but after ruth told
him she killed his dad he's not going
he's living the dream squatting in rich
people's vacation homes but that
eventually gets him into trouble ruth
tries to bail him out but he doesn't
want anything to do with her and darlene
snell happened to be there is like i'll
pay the kids bail now darlene still has
baby zeke and wendy absolutely hates
that in fact she goes to pick a fight
with her one day calls her a redneck
well that did it she tries to get
custody taken away but wyatt was there
as a witness like yo wendy started it so
darlene gets to keep baby zeke for now
so darlene and wife have become real
close maybe too close they start doing
it i try not to judge but there's a bit
of an age difference meanwhile agent
maya miller has a deal for marty she
knows he'll never testify against the
cartel but she has a different option
he's so good at what he does if he
pleads guilty to a separate offense then
he can come work for the fbi to catch
other money launderers he'd serve 18
months in prison so the cartel knows he
didn't rat and then he'd be free before
his mexico trip marty wanted to take
this deal but now he's got a different
plan he wants to help her solve other
financial crimes while not taking any
deal and still working for the cartel
but she's like marty you can't have your
cake and eat it too now wendy hates this
idea of turning an fbi agent and she and
marty start arguing more than ever in
fact now wendy tries to bribe the
therapist to take her side and finally
the therapist like yo you both bribed me
this sets off their biggest fight yet it
looks like their marriage might be fully
over but they forgot the therapist was
in the room they spoke pretty explicitly
about the cartel marty's got to give her
an even bigger bribe to stay quiet but
she uses it to buy a sports car and
helen pierce is like oh hell nah that's
an unacceptable security risk she has
her silenced permanently meanwhile ben
has a huge crush on ruth and no one's
really flirted with her before she's not
sure what's happening but he takes her
on her dream date of putting birdseed on
frank junior's car messing with frank jr
is the way to her heart unfortunately
ben's bipolar medication makes it hard
to get hard so he decides to get off his
meds and get it on he and roof fall in
love but now he's acting erratic again
made worse because he saw marty abducted
to mexico they got to tell him about the
cartel and he does not take the news
well then there's a new big problem with
ruth's next money drop with the kc mob
they park far away just to mess with her
but that saves her life when men from
the lagunas cartel come and kill them
all yeah the cartel wars just crossed
the border frank jr thinks it's pretty
sus ruth survived thinks she set his man
up and he touches her touches her so
hard he almost kills her this was very
much against the rules so marty's like
yo our deal's off we're cutting ties but
to ruth that's kind of a cop-out i'm
supposed to be untouchable you gotta
retaliate and ruth being hurt sends ben
off the deep end he crashes his sister's
fancy fundraiser punches marty in the
face then he makes things much worse
when he goes to helen pierce's house and
starts yelling at her about working for
the cartel in front of her daughter who
the one rule was she can't know so
before helen can have him killed when he
takes her brother on the run but he
keeps buying burner phones and calling
helen trying to apologize he's not
getting the situation finally wendy
realizes there's nowhere she can take
her brother where he'll be safe so they
sit down for one last brother-sister
dinner wendy goes to the bathroom but
she never comes back instead helen's
cartel killer comes oh wendy gave up her
brother to keep the peace it totally
breaks her wendy takes a few days off to
process her emotions with a nice
staycation in the walmart parking lot
and when she gets home this has put
things in perspective she and marty work
their issues out for ruth though this
went too far wendy killed her dad and
now her boyfriend she's like sorry marty
it's been real but i quit so now wyatt
langmore patches things up with his
cousin darlene's been telling him hey
it's not ruth's fault it's that marty
bird and darlene takes advantage of ruth
and marty split she tracks down frank jr
and blows his dick off yeah messing with
frank jr is the way to root's art and
darlene somehow smooths things over with
his dad like hey we can go to war or you
can get rich partnering with me on my
heroine so ruth and wyatt langmore are
now working for darlene snell jonah is
also very upset by his uncle ben's death
in fact he busts into helens with a gun
for revenge but she's like hey kid it
was your mom who made the call in the
end so now jonah's real mad so now
helen's like wendy you did the right
thing let's move forward put this behind
us but she secretly goes to navarro like
hey the birds are trouble magnets you
need to kill them and put me in charge
but the birds figure out helen's coming
for him they need a plan to be more
valuable and the answer is the cartel
war which is not going well navarro is
losing but if a cartel commits violence
on american soil like how the lagunas
cartel attacked their truck then the us
government can go down to retaliate so
the birds hope to get to the us
government to win the cartel war for
navarro but when the birds are summoned
to mexico maya gives them some bad news
turns out helen's play was to negotiate
a fake deal for marty with the fbi
making it look like he's snitching so
navarro's probably gonna kill him but
it's too late to turn back now so down
in mexico things look bleak for the
birds is this the end but oh no it's
helen that they kill navarro's like
what's up birds you guys are fun i like
you better so now marty and wendy bird
in deeper with the cartel than ever and
their family is safe for now but
long-term job security seems iffy and
that's where ozark season 3 comes to an
end
if you like this recap hit that
subscribe button for more of the best
recaps of tv and movies and if you love
this recap check out the join button and
support the channel as a member